in germany a 96 year old woman is on
trial for nazi war crimes she's accused
of helping murder more than 11 thousand
people at a concentration camp emgard
ferkner was in court yesterday
prosecutors are racing to bring cases
against nazi suspects who are still
alive either in germany or in the united
states 110 suspects living in the u.s
have been identified for nazi crimes
since
1973 but only five were later tried in
germany charlie dagda is at the court
outside hamburg
good morning the defendant is 96 years
old she lives in a nearby nursing home
she's confined to a wheelchair yet at
one point she tried to make a run for it
and now wears an electronic tag in short
she wants nothing to do with this trial
arm guard fuchner was wheeled into the
courtroom to face the charges accessory
to murder of thousands of people
including the systematic extermination
of thousands of jews
her lawyers say she rejects that she's
personally responsible for any crime but
as the secretary to the commandant of
the stutter concentration camp in nazi
occupied poland lawyers representing
victims say she cannot deny involvement
you can't work
almost two years in a concentration camp
in an extermination camp where
every day people were murdered
without knowing what was going on there
the trial here reflects how german
prosecutors are now racing against time
in chasing down the convictions of lower
ranking nazi suspects thanks to a
landmark ruling
in 2011 a german court found john demian
guilty of being an accessory to murder
for being a prison guard at another
concentration camp opening the door for
similar prosecutions ben cohen's
grandmother survived stuttolf her mother
did not
she was ripped from her mother's arms
as her mother was selected for the gas
chamber
and she spent the rest of her life
telling her story
for those who couldn't
ben's grandmother judy meisel passed
away last year he said trials like this
are important because it reminds the
world of the horrors of the holocaust
while those responsible are still alive
for cbs mornings charlie dagetta near
hamburg
germany